how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and this is going to be my
explanation of the ending of black widow
and explaining the post credit scene as
well in this video i'll be talking about
what exactly happened at the end of
black widow when thunderbolt ross and
the rest of the us government was coming
for black widow and her family
what happens to taskmaster the rest of
the widows yelena balova
and including what exactly is going on
in that post-credits scene and how
it most likely sets up a brand new team
that is going to be coming to the mcu
that you should be very
excited for i'll break it all down in
this video and if you're new and you
want to stay up to date on all things
relating to the mcu be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos so black widow takes place
between the events of captain america
civil war and the events of avengers
infinity war
at the end of captain america civil war
since natasha actually chose to help
bucky in captain america
she was deemed an enemy of the state
along with the rest of
captain america's team however she was
not one of the members that got captured
at the end
and put on the raft the raft is a
maximum security prison in the middle of
the ocean that was controlled by
thunderbolt ross
ant-man was locked away hawkeye was
locked away the scarlet witch was locked
away and sam was as well
and in the black widow movie we see what
natasha was up to this entire time
after civil war in black widow as you
saw we see that natasha reunites with
her so-called family
back from when she used to work for the
russian government her sister
yelena her mother molina and her father
alexis shostakov aka the red guardian
natasha
was trained in the red room along with
her sister elena but natasha thought
that the red room was taken down
years and years ago however this of
course was not true so she reunites with
her sister
then her mother then her father after
they break him out of jail and they go
attack the red room to bring down dracov
and release all of the widows we find
out that the widows are actually being
controlled by some type of serum
drakov has figured out how to mind
control the widows they are essentially
his puppets that will do anything he
tells them to do and he can even kill
them
remotely after a few fights with
taskmaster and a one-on-one with drakov
eventually the family takes down the red
room releasing all of the widows from
drakov's mind control
here we also find out the secret
identity of taskmaster as it turns out
it was actually drakov's daughter
antonia drakov natasha thought that she
had killed dracov's daughter in an
explosion this is also referenced in the
very first avengers film when loki is
talking to natasha natasha explains that
she has red in her ledger and she needs
to make it clean
but loki then says can you really wipe
out that much red
then he says drakov's daughter referring
to natasha killing her and she was just
a little girl
but of course we learned that she
actually lived dracov managed to save
his daughter by putting a chip inside of
her neck and he could also control her
as well
and she goes on to become taskmaster now
eventually natasha and her family do
take down the red room and they manage
to kill dracov once and for all
they released all of the black widows
from being mind controlled including
taskmaster and they let them free from
here
yolina the widows taskmaster or antonia
drakov
red guardian and molina would all escape
while black widow would stay behind to
help them we know they escape but we
don't actually see what natasha does
we see thunderbolt ross and the us
government driving their convoys towards
her but we don't see them interact
however judging by one of the first
scenes of the actual film it's very
clear that natasha is pretty much on
another level than thunderbolt ross and
his men
and could probably easily escape which
we know she does because then she goes
on to join captain america
the final scene is her meeting up once
again with former shield agent rick
mason
he gives her a quinjet and she goes on
and rejoins captain america in helping
break out the rest of the team
from here her captain america and falcon
would be
the secret avengers and they would do
their own personal secret missions
until they would eventually return and
unite for avengers infinity war
now we actually know everything that
happens to natasha unfortunately she
would go on to sacrifice herself and die
in avengers in game
so the new questions are what happened
to yolina bolova
what happened to the widows and what
happened to the red guardian
and molina we'll get to what yelena is
up to when we talk about the
post-credits scene
as far as the rest of the widows we can
assume that some of them probably did
what yelena and black widow did
some would probably go on and live
relatively normal lives and simply enjoy
their freedom
others might go on and try to correct
the wrongs of their past
and some just like yelena could even be
recruited for some government agencies
one thing is certain and that is that we
have not seen the last of them
and as far as taskmaster is concerned
i'm assuming that she might be right
beside yelena
working for val as well which we're
about to get into but as far as
alexi shostakov aka the red guardian and
molina are concerned they most likely
ran away together
molina seemed to be off of the grid and
away from the red room at the time
and now that the red room is gone
there's no reason that she couldn't go
back to what she was doing before
although this time she really wouldn't
have to worry about anyone coming after
her
and of course since her and alexi had a
relationship before it's safe to assume
that they're probably going to continue
that so the two of them are probably at
molina's home leading a relatively
normal life now that is until the mcu at
some point needs the red guardian or
molina
now the post-credits scene is actually
really really exciting
for starters we finally get a proper
tribute to
natasha we finally see her gravestone
now this isn't exactly a funeral like a
lot of people wanted at the end of
avengers in-game
but this is our chance to mourn to pay
our respects to natasha in a proper way
her sister yelena visits her with her
dog sheds some tears for her and clears
off her grave
however she is not alone she is quickly
joined by valentina allegra de fontaine
played by julia louise dreyfus
now valentina or val was originally
introduced in the falcon and the winter
soldier however she was supposed to be
introduced in black widow first
but due to covet 19 and some shifting in
the release schedules the falcon and the
winter soldier premiered before black
widow
in the falcon and the winter soldier she
recruited the former
captain america john walker as the new
u.s
agent something that happened in the
comics as well john walker became us
agent and now as we see in the black
widow post-credits scene yelena has
already been recruited
and actually works for val it's clear
that val works for some type of us
government
now it may be a little shady and it may
be sanctioned by thunderbolt ross
in a not so legitimate way but one thing
is clear valentina is forming a team
a team made out of highly skilled
individuals right now she has yolina
bilova who of course is a super assassin
u.s agent john walker who now is a super
soldier and since jelena was with
taskmaster at the end of black widow
taskmaster slash and tonya drakup could
very well be working for val
as well especially if they don't really
give them a chance
yelena and antonia are both products of
the red room they've done many illegal
things and probably have committed war
crimes throughout their time in the red
room
if the government got a hold of them
this could be their plea bargain
do some work on a team and then earn
your freedom this most likely is the
start of the formation of
the thunderbolts team or the dark
avengers it's unclear right now on which
direction they're going to take this new
team
in the mcu but it's very clear that this
new team is going to consist of members
who aren't exactly like captain america
they're a little bit more rough and
willing to do just a little bit more
than the old avengers team would do to
get the job done
in the comics the thunderbolts actually
consist of former villains trying to
earn their freedom
baron zemo who we saw in the falcon in
the winter soldier is a member
the winter soldier in the comics is a
member hawkeye is actually a member at
one point in time too
deadpool as well but in the mcu it's
looking like the first two members are
u.s agent john walker and yolina bulova
and only the future of the mcu will tell
us who the rest of this team
is now the post-credits scene ends with
something very shady happening
val lies to elena and tells her that
hawkeye
killed natasha val shows yolena her next
target and it's a picture of
hawkeye val explains that this is
yelena's chance to go after the man who
killed her sister
now obviously we know that's a lie
however
yelena does not and what this does is
set up a showdown between yelena and
hawkeye in the upcoming hawkeye series
on disney plus
now another important thing to note is
that valentina in the comics
is actually known as madame hydra she's
a double agent that actually betrays
shield and this is very shady behavior
that we're seeing in this post-credits
scene her story is probably going to be
different in the mcu
it does seem like she is working for the
us government but it seems like she
pretty much has the authority to kind of
do whatever she wants
she's already pretty shady as it is
putting together a very shady team so
this is probably who her character is
going to be a character that's not
exactly good
but not exactly bad but one thing is for
sure it's definitely going to be
exciting to see this team when they
finally make their mcu debut
in the meantime let me know what you
thought about the black widow movie in
the comments down below
what was your favorite part again don't
forget to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the videos don't forget to
like the video and for live updates you
can always follow me on instagram and
twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof